CREW
Ready and action!
COBIE SMULDERS
When we start Secret Invasion,
Nick Fury has been off planet and
Maria Hill has just really been
trying to you know, maintain order.
But this current threat
is getting out of control.
AGENT PRESCOTT
Five global terrorist strikes
within the past year, each one
claimed by a different group.
EVERETT ROSS
It's business as usual.
AGENT PRESCOTT
That's precisely what they
want you to think.
SAMUEL L. JACKSON
Nick comes back having lost
whatever power he had before.
So, we try and solve things
without being too superhuman.
ART GALLERY OWNER
Are you going to shoot me?
NICK FURY
Maybe. Oh, probably.
But not right now.
COBIE SMULDERS
We get to jump into Nick Fury's world,
which is very spy versus spy.
BEN MENDELSOHN
The kind of grittiness, the locations,
the way it feels, the way
it's written. It's a thriller.
TALOS
Fury, we gotta be very careful now.
ALI SELIM
I had to pinch myself many mornings
when I would step on set with
Olivia Colman, Sam Jackson,
Don Cheadle, Emilia Clarke,
Ben Mendelsohn, Kingsley Ben-Adir.
I mean, some of my favorite
actors in the world.
SONYA FALSWORTH
Alone at Last.
OLIVIA COLMAN
After every Marvel film released,
I would phone my agent and say,
"Please, can I be in a Marvel thing?"
I never imagined it would happen.
[Groan]
GOON
What makes you think
you can get him to speak?
SONYA FALSWORTH
Oh, I can be quite persuasive.
DON CHEADLE
Looking at the MCU through these
different lenses, you get to see all
these different sides of the characters.
So, we get to really sort
of dig into who they are.
NICK FURY
How much do you know about
your security detail?
JAMES RHODES
What do you mean, how much
do I know about it?
EMILIA CLARKE
This idea of who can you trust?
That is really the heart of the show.
COBIE SMULDERS
It could be talking to somebody
you have a very close relationship
with, and then you find out that
that's not who you thought it was.
DON CHEADLE
It becomes sort of a cat and mouse game
that we build toward to
the end of the show.
EMILIA CLARKE
You can't predict it,
and you can't preempt it.
And you can't fathom it
until it happens.
NICK FURY
I'm Nick Fury.
Even when I'm out, I'm in.